right here on the rich eisen show in
person thrilled to have right here a fan
of this man's work in so many different
things that he's done from again
shawshank redemption starship troopers
terrific and lost the informant is
another fun movie that he was in back in
the days bad boy and now bad boys and
now he kind of plays one uh in dexter
new blood airing sundays at nine eastern
on showtime the man who played captain
hadley back in the day and shawshank
redemption now here on the rich eisen
show clancy brown what a pleasure to see
you sir what a pleasure to be here rich
thank you so much i even mentioned
billions which you were fantastic in so
much as well
so we'll talk about all of this but for
the first things first you are from the
state of ohio correct indeed i am okay
so uh lay out your fandom uh on the
floor if foreign heartbreaking loss um
but uh which which loss are we referring
to the loss of the big game okay a
couple couple weeks ago but yes but rich
i have to say i did watch your take on
it okay and it was
it was epic
it was it was poetic it was so as a
as a as a you know born ohioan who
automatically roots for ohio state no
matter what even though i went to uh
another big ten school you went to
northwest went to northwestern okay my
wife went to iowa i mean you know we're
a big ten family but
you know i i root for ohio state all the
time i can't help but think yes
that it was
really good for the big ten
that michigan won oh i appreciate you
saying that i think it was really good
for the big tank because i got really
tired of oh god of
two teams being in it okay you know it's
like the sec
you know it's always alabama
yeah in big ten it was always it was
always ohio state okay you know so we've
just met and i don't know if this is you
being passive
when i was a kid that's when i became
sports aware
paul brown and woody hayes were the
coaches in the nation that is ohio the
football nation
and uh it's kind of
deteriorated since then as far as i'm
concerned but uh
i i think these teams have to you know
this college football is getting boring
so you need to mix it up a little so we
need to mix it up and we got to have
michigan back i mean look oh gosh
okay
michigan
see these are all the touchstones from
ohio state folks that i get that
glad to have you back we need to go
ahead and have you back we do we do and
but you you got one thing wrong and
you're saying
in your second one
when they made the cfp which is which is
your your little catty comment about
michigan state that hurt
that hurts you
michigan state always hurts michigan
states hurts every
it hurts ohio state hurts michigan no i
didn't lost no no it's definitely hurt
and i lost it i fully admit that we that
loss to michigan state it hurts it
definitely it hurts and it left a mark
but it's now just a
you know it's the bruce the bruise is
fading right um and it's now just it
it's not a scar it's nothing permanent
you described it as the your
best yeah no no no no you described it
as the the the best day of your life the
best week of your life that's true you
wake up in the next day is even better
than the best day
it was epic it was so good it was so
good thank you guys
thank you there is that little
spider bite of
sparty yes dominating
yes
that's that that is that that is there
but it is it was just a character
building loss that without it i mean we
had 18 hundreds in on this week he said
that without that loss they might not be
big ten champions right now so you know
i
[Music]
island show you mentioned paul brown and
woody hayes are the coaches of your
youth and how you kind of fell in love
with sports in ohio football are you
still a bengal now are you still rooting
for the bangladesh yeah yeah no question
okay no question joe barro a kid from
athens being the quarterback so why not
cleveland is that all why not cleveland
[Laughter]
i mean i like i like cleveland
but they moved to baltimore
ah right okay they moved to baltimore so
i'm having uh i'm trying to learn to
love these new cleveland browns okay so
but i despise the baltimore ravens
because they abandon the nation-state of
ohio
so it's not a cleveland
perspective i'm not a cleveland guy i'm
i'm i'm southern ohio because i didn't i
don't know for the indians i root for
the reds you know okay so i thought you
were doing like a sam weich thing you
know like you're not in cleveland you're
from cincinnati i think cleveland but
that's a different cleveland team too
thank you very much for sure right so um
no i don't i i don't hate cleveland i
don't hate cleveland all right i i would
root for them if they won okay i mean i
like my my fandom of convenience is la
and the charities the rams and the
chargers and the ones in my heart are
cleveland okay and the cavs are you a
cavs guy not really basketball you're
not really a basketball guy all right
clancy brown here uh on the rich eisen
show so much to talk to you about right
here on the show uh the first things
first the movie or tv show that you get
the most when people see you is what
the latest one
is all right
whatever's on at the time is that right
but uh of all of them i'd say probably
shawshank it is that yeah and and
spongebob what was in sponge because
you're the voice of uh mr [ __ ] mr krabs
do you get people saying can you record
something all the time
all the time i get that
that's pretty much it yep every time for
their kids for the kids i tell their
kids to send me all their money
and one time it happened
and then i stopped doing it then you
stopped yeah okay
all right and so uh shawshank did you
have any sense at the time shooting that
film
what you were
endeavoring at that moment no no i mean
nobody ever did and we didn't even when
it opened nobody thought it was really i
mean we we knew it was a good movie you
always know it's a good script it's a
good movie it was an a-list group of
guys and and it was a group of guys and
it was in my home state we shot it in
mansfield so you know i was as happy as
could be
rare rabbit but um
you know you never you never know if
anything's going to be any good
you hope you hope against hope uh you
put together all the best guys you had
terry marsh who was the uh
the designer and you had roger deakins
who was the
photographer the dp
you know it was a real a-list group of
folks
but you never know what's going to
happen i mean
you know i've been in movies where
there's an a-list group of folks and
they're just completely tanks and it
didn't do well at the box office
initially it's it's love came from
ancillary markets from vhs right being
on tbs
[Laughter]
it was on last night right it was it was
on last night it's totally honest so so
you're sometimes slipping around the
channels and boom yeah there it is yeah
always what's your favorite scene from
the film what do you which one do you
love
where you're like that was any scene
that morgan is narrating i yeah that
works right yeah i love that what's my
favorite scene i don't know
um
uh
you know the end that the is just
brilliant
um but you're not in that one no no no i
don't i don't like any of the scenes i
mean are you kidding no
i can only look at it and think how i
would have done it better you got
something oh well that's what i wanted
to ask you because your character is
such a sob right like
what scene of yours kind of makes your
stomach curl we're like man this guy is
a terrible dude uh he's certainly the
first one you know where the
where he beats up
the fat ass guy
mesh fish yeah fresh fish and it's funny
enough
later on in my career
i ran into him again on er
and killed him again
yeah he came in as an emergency patient
that that and i was kind of a
you know whatever the hot doctor was at
the time and i had to i had to give him
amps of epi and all that stuff and and
he goes you know he goes flatline on me
so
i killed him twice
i killed him twice not on purpose so if
he ever shows up on set with you one
more time he'll be like oh no yeah i
know
i've got no shot here
oh my gosh clancy brown here uh on on
the uh rich eisen show okay and before
we hit uh dexter new blood there's a
whole bunch of other questions about you
and your career um that i want to know
is true or false we've got all of these
stories that have been written about you
or facts on the internet oh i got one
for you okay so oh this will be great
celebrity true or false me for clancy
brown and apparently one one for me and
the other direction uh go ahead and hit
it this is our production value with all
of it here we go
celebrity true or false you can't handle
the truth
all right that's it that's all we got
that's our production value awesome okay
here we go first question for you uh
clancy brown true or false you
originally attended northwestern we know
that's true on a track scholarship as a
discus thrower but switched majors to
theater arts after two seasons is that
true
yes that's true although i wasn't
majoring in track um which annoyed my
coach don amity but uh
um
especially since she went on a
scholarship right yeah yeah he told me
he told me just you know keep the
scholarship just invite him to the
to a show are you serious yeah yeah he's
a great guy he was a great guy how far
could you throw a discus uh when i was
when i was concentrating good i think i
got like 160 when it's you know touching
170. damn but
you know it's look man
those guys in the big ten are big i mean
i'm sort of big but they're really big
so when they were football players that
weren't on football scholarship right
that weren't the track players and
that's back in the day when steroids
were good for you
you know i mean you know it was just it
was
there were there were prices i was not
willing to pay back then yeah oh my gosh
all right next one up um true or false
you were cast in a highlander at the
recommendation of sting that's true too
yeah well i hear that's true
that story is that the the they were
they had offered it to arnold who said
arnold schwarzenegger who had said you
know i just i just did a bad guy i did
the terminator i'm not interested in
playing another bad guy right and uh so
russell mulcahy the director was uh he
was from
uh uh videos music videos yes he was uh
australian guy or new zealand i'm not
sure which but
he uh he was at some party with uh you
know rock and roll party because that's
what they do and knew sting and i had
just done the bride with sting and and
uh i think he said well you should look
at uh this yank that i worked with he
seemed like a nice guy and a pretty good
actor and he's big and you know and
that's how you got it
that's how you got in the movie
highlander huh well that and the fact
that i was really not expensive at the
time
so yeah i mean you know got to be lucky
and inexpensive and good
that's at the crossroads of lucky
inexpensive and good and so what was
thing like did you
he was just terrific he's the nicest guy
ever you know and sting and trudy both
they had us over to their house and
and you've done with stink what do you
call him do you call him stan
you don't call him gordon he's sting i
mean you know that's who he is so did
you just say hey sting you know i would
love to see him i haven't seen him since
i mean yeah he was he was very sweet guy
i think he got he is sort of
bored with the show after a while
because making movies boring sometimes
sure and so he started working on his
solo album the dream of blue turtles of
course you know about halfway through
the show so he was um
hey you know i mean you gave up discus
for something else you know i mean
that's his bread and butter all right uh
uh
true or false your first acting job
after moving to los angeles was playing
a bad guy in the dukes of hazard right
on second bet
number two
look at you on the screen right there
man yeah there i am
there's jeff joseph look at the stash
man yeah right you were in the dukes of
hazard huh i was thrilled because um
the episode was called too many roscoes
and we it was the
conceit was that we we had found a
double for jim best who played the you
know the sheriff which i can't remember
the name of it yeah and we were going to
replace him and so i got to i got to sit
down with jim best and i started
fanboying out on him and he just was not
interested
did you get anywhere close to the
generally in any way shape or form uh
yeah i think it i think we hijacked it
at some point damn and but i didn't i i
didn't know a lot about the show uh
jeff
who was the other guy he he knew what to
do okay so good that he knew what to do
he
he jumped into it because you can't open
the door right apparently right so he
jumped in the window and
i think i just took jim best in the in
the prius that we had so did you
did you uh did you still get residual
checks from the dukes of hazard to this
day
yes
i i just got a check
i just got a check from my combined uh
two episodes of csi miami that i've been
in where i've played announcer and mail
announcer i've ranged clancy what got
range man uh combined 5.59 cents nice
yes that ain't nothing that is it ain't
nothing it heads up okay so fantastic
by the way i'll go under the sea
uh last one for you true or false in bad
boys sean penn asked the other actors to
actually spit on you in one scene
uh not on me on him okay i wasn't spit
on him yeah i wasn't at that scene yeah
um
yeah he he comes in and it's like the
fresh fish scene and he's got his
he's got his uh his clothes his gear
he's been through all the
all the uh intake uh process and so he
you know he wanted all the
all the kids to spit on him all the
extras to spit on him and
you know
and this is that was fine i guess
one of the actors i mean i didn't know
it was my first movie i you know i
wasn't going to spit on him but yes um
you know one of the actors insisted that
everybody brush their teeth and you know
have
before we
who really wasn't like the sean pan that
we know of then he was he was on his way
there but he's well i remember bad boys
it was like wait a minute jeff spicoli
is acting seriously right like right
exactly i remember back then that was
kind of stunning
that the guy who was brilliantly funny
and fast times is now is like he is a
serious actor yeah yeah yeah yeah my
debut you know who else is debuting who
is it who is alan wreck
huh wrecker was in that he was
he came on this show alan rock talking
about how he was 29
when he shot
uh ferris bueller's day off yeah and he
looks you know he's a little older than
me and he you know he looks 20 years
younger right that's that's just his
curse
so you and alan rock made this the dame
debut in bad boys you got a good sean
penn story because i know you've been in
other stuff with him uh no i haven't
that was the only one i've been in no
okay what's my sean penn story uh oh if
you don't have one i don't really have a
sean pennsylvania except that he was
going out with
with bruce springsteen's sister at the
time pamela
and i later ran into pamela as a uh as a
parent
we were both parents at the same
elementary school that's the way life
works right isn't it weird it is
certainly weird all right so what's your
true or false for me your first job out
of college was the style rcr
rtv yes right my wife also first job out
of college are you serious yeah yeah
no kidding yeah yeah right up there for
tv so what did she what did she be right
he was yeah right right yes yes and then
after you left california oregon
broadcasting incorporated right yeah
what did she do up there she did we work
together no she was a little bit before
you she did the the slot between good
morning america and something else she
said she did good morning california wow
you know
am whatever something like that yeah my
fr that's and she did a lot of this she
did a lot of interviewing people who
were supporting actors on tv shows man
it was for me i'm from new york city and
being up there in redding california
where we broadcast to every day in the
ready chico market where aaron rodgers
grew up right you know and just going up
in that beautiful part of the north
state it is so beautiful but i was in
new york i'm a new yorker going up there
it was like you know northern exposure
you know
it was like walking around and i'm like
panning for gold i could just fly
fishing
love it or do i love it or could you not
get out of there fast no i you know what
i want i just had a i had a vision about
getting to sportscenter as fast as i
possibly could but i loved it i like i
said i went you know i i went uh on a
houseboat on lake shasta and i drove all
over the place up there and it's close
to oregon than it is to san francisco
have you been back uh one a couple of
times yeah yeah now we haven't been back
in a while well you gotta try to get up
there so i got another one for you okay
like you won't know all right what is
that
true or false yes today is my mother's
birthday uh i'm going to say that's a
true story that is a true story ladies
and gentlemen happy birthday is my mom's
birthday okay all right
1929.
clancy bro 92 years old wow
hanging in there taking care of my dad
okay and we could all sing happy
birthday very good you want to do that
yeah sure okay here we go what's your
name again joyce okay here we go one two
three happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you
happy birthday
[Music]
happy birthday to you happy birthday mom
i love you yes i love it amazing okay um
so i am mandated to say what does your
mom think of your work in dexter new
blood she's not watching it
i'm not keeping her from watching it but
i'm not telling her how to operate the
remote i'm not explaining that i'm not
wait what is this showtime anytime thing
yeah i'm not getting into that with her
oh yeah yeah you have to you have to ask
your husband for that
i would say my mom's watching us on
peacock right now but the number of
times she's like so you're on what again
you know
uh at any rate
thank you for that i really appreciate
it of course absolutely so uh dexter new
blood sundays 9 p.m on showtime um i
know there's a lot to reveal about your
character i don't want to go places
where potentially
um you or the uh folks who make it uh
don't want me to go
but
you tell me i mean what you are like
about this while you're jumping on it
while you wanted to do this
and be part of this um
new i guess
rebirth of one of the more popular shows
of our time right um okay
i don't really have a rap about this yet
so i'm going to like try it work it out
i took it because it was the pandemic
and i hadn't worked in about a year okay
uh i do remember the first iteration of
it and um when it was being cast around
they were considering me for remarks
part for a second for a minute glad i
didn't do it because remar was so good
in it yes um and uh
i didn't watch it though as soon as like
as soon as they were interested i
started watching all of it and was kind
of amazed by how terrific it is now
the idea that you have a television show
a popular television show like a raging
fandom for a character that is a serial
killer
is just bizarre right
and so i'm supposed to play
the bad guy
right
i'm the bad guy right
for a serial killer yes
how am i not a victim
how am i not one of those victims
my character thinks he's pretty hot
stuff
and you know maybe he's killed a few
people
but nothing compared to dexter
my guy is kind of a
not he's not the sharpest knife in the
drawer yes
to the end he never calls him dexter he
doesn't connect that he calls him jim
he thinks he's jim
he doesn't realize that he's sitting
across in that picture there he doesn't
realize he's sitting across from
somebody who's on camera killed
a hundred and fifty people makes you
like an angel
but i'm the bad guy
i'm the bad guy
how are me and my family not victims of
this psycho killer thank you all right
great point clancy that you bring out oh
oh my god
[Laughter]
9 p.m on stream okay sunday night sunday
night it's 9 p.m on show time
love michael by the way michael's
terrific yeah he was on a few weeks ago
and the kid that's in it is terrific to
jack alcott yeah everybody and it was
really good a lot of fun that's again on
show time at 9 eastern time um i could
go on and on man rich i told clancy he
and i actually met a few years ago you
met everybody on a set of the movie the
guardian was kevin costner and ashton
right after katrina
they were set up it was a it was a coast
guard movie with uh
with kevin costner and ashley kutcher
and they had set up that built this big
thing in in new orleans a big tank
katrina comes in wipes out new orleans
so we all moved to shreveport
which
i'm sure the people of shreveport love
shreveport
it was not a fun place to for me to do
but you got to meet tj jefferson which
is a wonderful thing right i did very
good there you go i love it um and
anyways pulling the slots because we all
stayed in the casino
um and then uh before i let you go
billions holy crap were you just awesome
in that show well thanks i mean the
writing on that show it is true truly
amazing and then uh writers agree right
so i i met you you were in so many
scenes with paul giamatti i mean that
yes well there's another great story
right paulie's first movie ever was a
little movie that i was in also called
uh
past midnight with
rutger hauer he was doing he was in
washington
at seattle rep and i remember sitting
out we were sitting out by a car and he
said hey do you think i should
go to new york or go to la and and i you
know i just finished up i said well you
should stay here in seattle and do
theater of course but you know if you
want to go one place i said you
definitely got to go to la because
that's where the business is and of
course he was smart enough never to take
my advice right and went back and now
he's a huge giant star he is he is a
huge and he's a terrific terrific well i
mean
did you ever at any point in time as a
reds fan talk to him about his dad and
pete rose did you ever bring that up
with him yeah i did bring it up a couple
of times
you had to tread lightly i know you know
you do you do you do because i
i'm very uh i go back and forth about
pete pete pissed me off man pete that
whole episode pissed me off yeah better
yeah i know i it is it's such a very
touchy subject and obviously you know
i would love to talk to paul giamatti
and i don't think he talks about it at
all
no well i mean he lost his dad earlier
of course he was just a kid right
and what he's what he has become as an
actor i mean always
i know yeah known by fans of billions
and howard stern all over the place i
mean that's right that's what we say
we're we're on
handbc peacock
uh good to see you clancy brown pleasure
richard come on back anytime you got
anything uh you want to promote we're
here let's do it at realclancybrown on
twitter and instagram hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here